on may 25th 1977 a pop culture
phenomenon was born
after months of hype a movie called star
wars hit theaters
but what was it really like seeing the
film back in 1977.
we've gathered accounts from filmmakers
journalists and fans to take us back
to a galaxy far far away
while it took a week or two for star
wars fever to fully catch on nationwide
it was an overnight sensation in
california
the film premiered at grauman's chinese
theater in hollywood where it became
completely normal to see lines of fans
camped outside the movie house
actress carrie fisher told time magazine
it wasn't like
a movie opening it was like an
earthquake the chinese theater was at
the
epicenter of that earthquake and
thousands of fans were drawn to it every
day
speaking to cnn star wars fan chris
baldwick recalled traveling from the san
fernando valley to hollywood to see the
movie on may 26th
just one day after the film opened the
long line wound down the street from
grauman's chinese theater and around the
block
news helicopters hovered in the air
above the crowd star wars was the first
film to earn a reputation as a party
movie
the fans brought costumes beach balls
folding chairs for the line
and an almost palatable anticipation
there was no better place to see it than
grauman's chinese in its pre-multiplex
days on advice from 20th century fox the
owners of the famous theater only booked
star wars for a
two-week run when a scheduling conflict
meant
they couldn't show the hit film after
that they resorted to desperate measures
and refurbished an
old cinema larry gleason former
president of man theaters told the
hollywood reporter
we moved star wars there where it played
for two weeks before coming back to the
chinese
star wars toys would explode in
popularity over the next couple years
but
back when the film was first released
the toys weren't ready and all kids had
was the movie itself george lucas's film
became so popular with youngsters
that some of them were even ditching
school so they could see it
a lifelong fan patrick payne told
starwars.com
unless you lived through it and can
remember it's kind of hard for modern
audiences to understand
just how different the world was in 1977
just prior to the release of star wars
i had seen the trailers on tv and in the
theater months earlier
they didn't say much however what little
they showed had already triggered my
imagination
payne sought out the novelization of
star wars which had hit the shelves in
november 1976
after reading the book he knew that he
absolutely had to see the story play out
on the big screen
payne recalled that a little thing like
class wasn't going to stand in his way
i for one was not going to miss this
movie
even if i had to miss school therefore i
skipped school
sorry parents took the bus downtown and
saw the very first
show on opening day another young film
enthusiast who saw the film on opening
day was brad bird who would later direct
such hit films as ratatouille
and the incredibles he described to cnn
what happened in the theater
when darth vader appeared on screen for
the first time the audience
simultaneously
boos and hisses like it's a silent movie
in the mid to late 1970s there weren't a
lot of movies with
broad cross-generational appeal being
released
which is another reason why star wars
did so well
speaking to the official star wars
website on the 40th anniversary of the
film's release
artist paul bateman revealed that his
father wasn't really interested in
seeing a space movie at first
but he ended up having the time of his
life bateman fondly recalled
when we arrived at the theater the line
to buy tickets was around the block and
dad was bored waiting in the line
however not too
long after the opening scenes my dad
became just as engrossed in the film as
i was
he was cheering and reacting along with
every adult and child
in the audience california native fred
white had just turned eight years old
when star wars came out
and despite knowing absolutely nothing
about the film he was hugely excited
when his father told him
they were going to see it white
reminisced about that day to cnn
he said it's called star wars i clearly
remember thinking
star wars that's a weird name we saw it
that day
and i never thought it sounded weird
again like so many kids his age
star wars became a huge part of white's
childhood and he has shared a special
bond with his dad
since that day they even started a star
wars tradition
and went to the opening day of the next
two films together
one of the reasons star wars managed to
stay in theaters for so long
was because people were returning for
repeat viewings
there was even a healthy competition
breaking out among the fledgling
fandom when the topic came up on reddit
one user recalled seeing star wars over
a dozen times
the redditor wrote it was absolutely the
coolest thing ever
saw that sucker 14 times that summer
first movie i ever went to see more than
once
what do you wanna do tonight oh and if
you say see star wars again i'm leaving
you don't want to leave another reddit
user recalled seeing it at least once a
week for the entire summer after getting
his initially reluctant friends hooked
on the film
when it finally made it to the discount
theater we went as groups
every weekend through year's end of
course going to see a movie
isn't free it's all well and good when
you're an adult with a job to support
your new star wars obsession but
how did kids in the 1970s managed to see
the film
so many times well 13 year old russell
burgess and his friend scott
maximized their budget by getting three
showings for the price of one
he admitted to cnn we rode our bikes
seven
miles to the biggest cinema in our area
waited in line
three hours and then sat through three
viewings in a row
hiding behind the screen curtains and in
the emergency exit stairwells
while the theater was cleaned between
shows
in a passionate medium article star wars
fan rob connery said that seeing the
movie in theaters at age nine
was a life-altering experience for him
reminding younger film fans just
how unique it was at the time according
to connery it wasn't
just the visual effects that made star
wars unlike
anything people had seen before it was
the whole package
he wrote most movies you would go see as
a kid were kind of crappy
i remember really liking escape to witch
mountain and herbie movies but as i grew
older i wanted something more
more adventure and yes a little bit of
suspense and scariness too
we just didn't have that back then it
was all
goofy disney trek that all
changed when star wars came along
according to connery it was the perfect
escape activity for the pre-internet age
when kids didn't have endless
entertainment at their fingertips
connery added there was absolutely
nothing like star wars when it came out
i'm struggling to come up with some
relevant analogy for movies today
something that makes you jump up and
scream
that alters your life profoundly and
makes you believe in space travel
exotic alien planets and the force much
like connery
fans from around the globe had their
eyes and minds
opened to endless possibilities by this
film
you've taken your first step into a
larger world
patty hammond creator of the everyday
fangirl blog won tickets to see star
wars from a local tv station
the trouble was the theater was a
40-mile round-trip
journey from her family home hammond
wrote about the experience for
starwars.com
back then the freeway system was not
what it is today and a trip to the
theater took over an hour however with
dad being a big science fiction fan we
decided to do it
lucas's space opera more than lived up
to her
and her father's expectations hammond
elaborated
when we came out of the theater he said
mark my words
this movie will become a classic boy
did he predict that one of course back
then it wasn't uncommon to drive to a
movie
and see it without ever having to leave
your vehicle star wars played as a
double feature with smokey and the
bandit at a number of drive-in theaters
including one in kansas where cnet's
bonnie burton was watching in
awe from the back of a pickup truck
burton remembers with
wonder the experience of seeing star
wars outdoors
i can't adequately express the fun of
watching skywalker blow up the death
star on a big screen beneath a sky full
of twinkly stars
as an imaginative kid it was hard to see
where the star wars galaxy ended
and our own night sky began after that
experience i'd stare up at the sky
throughout my childhood hoping to see
the millennium falcon
zip by earth on its way to coruscant one
of the reasons that star wars got such
an enthusiastic welcome in 1977 is
because there wasn't a whole lot of joy
at the time
george lucas's debut feature thx 1138
was a dark
gritty sci-fi experience but he grew up
adoring characters
like flash gordon and wanted to capture
that type of magic with an uplifting
tale of good versus evil
lucas's vision apparently didn't go down
well among veteran sci-fi writers who
didn't want to see the genre watered
down for younger viewers
august rogoni who saw the movie on
opening day told tested
they hated that star wars legitimized
sci-fi
but at the time we needed star wars
we had a recession we had an energy
crisis and we needed some
serious escapism it was the perfect
adventure movie for a kid
and the kid in everyone according to
rogoni
star wars lifted and connected people
the longtime sci-fi fan also said
it was a moment in time and a shared
experience that happened in cities all
across america
it caught everybody off guard and
something like that hasn't happened
since even veteran broadcast journalist
walter
cronkite spoke highly of the film when
he was interviewed for the documentary
empire of dreams the story of the star
wars trilogy
cronkite had this to say george lucas's
star wars lifted us out of our
depression of the 70s and
into an awareness and focus on space and
its possible future
this movie stood by itself lucas himself
had a similar perspective on the film
and
why it was so successful it's been a
long time since
people have been able to go to the
movies and see a
sort of straightforward wholesome fun
adventure
believe it or not some people weren't
that into star wars when they saw it on
the big screen in 1977
while many veteran film critics such as
roger ebert waxed
lyrical about the film some of his peers
were definitely not impressed
joy gould boyam wrote in the wall street
journal there's something depressing
about seeing all these impressive
cinematic gifts and all this
extraordinary technological skill
lavished on such
pure isle materials i find your lack of
faith
disturbing it's hard to understand
now but some viewers were so
underwhelmed that
they actually walked out of the film
speaking to starwars.com phantomy steele
revealed that she watched the majority
of the movie
alone at a theater in small town
mississippi after friends decided to get
up and leave
we arrived a little late as usual just
as r2 and 3po were walking across the
stands of tatooine
about 15 minutes later my friends
declared the movie to be lame
and walked out i stayed by myself and
fell in love with luke skywalker
han solo and princess leah i met with
them again the following night
and again the following weekend although
it's tame by today's standards for some
younger viewers star wars was actually a
little too violent
in the uk one young girl complained
about the scene in which alec guinness
obi-wan kenobi protects luke and slices
off panda baba's arm with a swift stroke
of his lightsaber
it's exciting but i didn't like the vic
when the man chopped off
the person's arm why not and they
because there was blood
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]